At first I can't believe
that I was accused of something like that to my
family my children were with me
we were camping I did not have to show my
phone
and I was
accused of something that I did not do
I
do everything for my children they
are my reasons all the time  days
to move forward and this
I can't think if one day
that happened to my son
here the real culprit of the murderer
of this child
deserves justice otherwise we also
have to support if someone knows
come forward say something and help
search here  the person who killed that child
to the public are teachers to my family
sorry for what we went through thank you
for me it is important because I have not
had a business here in the community
many people know me more expressly
many people are
going to see my children play soccer
soccer sports a lot of people and they are going to look at me
I don't want people to think that
I am capable of doing something like that to
begin with I don't know how they wanted him and camacho
cisneros could think that I was
I am  able to be in a vacuum
the detectives the police the
florences everyone involved in
this did their job for us well they could
risk my life and the lives of my children and
we liked that on my part I am innocent
this